[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
bienvenue dans Sciences publiques c'est
parti pour 90 minutes d'analyse de
l'actualité des reportages des experts
du temps pour débattre en profondeur la
volonté de prendre du recul sur les
événements c'est le cocktail que l'on
vous propose tous les soirs à 18h et 22h
sur Public Sénat avec deux chiffres ce
soir le 11 d'abord comme la 11e journée
de mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites séquence impressionnantes
d'unités syndicale qui continue même
s'il y avait aujourd'hui moins de
grévistes et de manifestants
que cette réforme est totalement injuste
moi personnellement j'ai eu la chance de
partir à 62 ans et demi et je pense que
c'est injuste pour les pour les gens qui
font des métiers difficiles comment
maintenir la pression dans les jours et
les semaines qui viennent même après la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel la
semaine prochaine réponse dans une
minute et puis notre second chiffre
c'est 3000 comme 3000 milliards d'euros
le montant de la dette française et la
flambée pendant la crise covid elle nous
coûte de plus en plus cher avec la
remontée des taux d'intérêt est-elle
soutenable la réforme des retraites on y
revient a-t-elle été lancé pour calmer
nos créanciers et nos partenaires
européens on en débat dans trois quarts
d'heure mais d'abord notre reportage au
cœur de la manifestation parisienne avec
Cécile siksu et Jonathan Dupriez
près de 400 000 personnes à Paris selon
la CGT et des tensions en marge du
cortège
les syndicats ne lâchent rien et
comptent sur la mobilisation de la rue
pour faire pression sur le gouvernement
après le refus hier d'Elisabeth borne de
retirer le projet de loi je crois qu'il
y a plus que la rue quasiment qui peut
faire quelque chose contre la réforme
des retraites on a vu hier lors de notre
discussion avec la première ministre qui
a pas eu de gestes d'ouverture qui a pas
eu de retrait qui a pas il y a aucune
solution dans le dialogue pour arriver à
faire retirer cette loi aujourd'hui le
gouvernement il est quand même dans
l'impasse il veut tourner la page nous
ne voulons pas et donc il est coincé
donc c'est la rue qui fait que le
gouvernement est dans l'impasse s'il ne
retire pas cette réforme on ne passera
pas à autre chose on refusera il ne
pourra plus gouverner réformer le pays
le gouvernement attend de son côté la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel le
14 avril prochain pour passer à autre
chose mais pour Laurent Berger
secrétaire général de la CFDT même si
les mobilisations commencent à peser
pour les salariés le malaise est
désormais profond
on peut nous arguer des statistiques des
uns et des autres la réalité c'est qu'il
y a un malaise social
qui a une crise sociale et que depuis
quelques temps ça se commence à se
transformer en crise démocratique les
syndicats comptent sur l'ascension du
projet de loi par les sages du Conseil
constitutionnel notre option serait que
l'institution donne son feu vert à
l'organisation d'un référendum
d'initiative partagée pour retarder la
promulgation de la loi
[Musique]
je vous présente tout de suite mes
invités on a beaucoup de thèmes à
aborder avec eux Franck Morel bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes avocat associé à
Flichy Grangé avocat ancien conseiller
social du Premier ministre Édouard
Philippe Christelle crablé bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes directrice de BVA
opinion Laurent fraggermann bonsoir
bienvenue à vous aussi sociologue
historien spécialiste des mouvements
sociaux et j'accueille également
Mathilde Sirault bonsoir Mathilde
bienvenue à vous comme chaque jeudi
depuis quelques semaines vous êtes les
journalistes politiques Franck Morel
kelbien vous faites de cette journée je
commence avec vous est-ce que c'était
moi j'ai ressenti un peu les deux c'est
à la fois une nouvelle démonstration de
force je trouve parce que ça fait 11
journées que ça dure c'est un temps long
l'Inter syndical l'unité syndicale est
toujours là et en même temps bon voilà
un symbole peut-être des difficultés à
maintenir le la mobilisation si je
cherche une image je dirais qu'on est
sur un faux plat d'une certaine manière
c'est-à-dire on se situe dans une
période qui est la période qui sépare le
vote par le Parlement achevé par le
mécanisme du 40 9 3 et puis qui précède
la décision du Conseil constitutionnel
qui permettra de savoir si la loi peut
être promulguée et donc cette période
elle est assez longue en réalité
puisqu'elle va nous mener jusqu'au
jusqu'au 14 avril et chacune des parties
gouvernement d'un côté organisation
syndicale de l'autre bat doit occuper le
terrain pendant ce laps de temps alors
on évoquera sans doute tout à l'heure la
réunion de Matignon hier forcément
forcément effectivement dans ce cadre-là
avec des signaux de part et d'autre qui
ont été envoyés dans ce dans ce contexte
mais on le voit bien donc il faut se
rappeler d'une chose je voudrais donner
un deuxième chiffre c'est aujourd'hui la
onzième journée de mobilisation lors de
la réforme de 2010 il y avait eu 14
journées de mobilisation donc on est
encore dans un étiage à réforme
équivalente puisque c'était déjà une
réforme qui élevait l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite de 60 à 62 ans et
qui était aussi extrêmement contestée
par l'ensemble des organisations
syndicales et par l'opinion publique à
l'époque et donc on avait eu 14 journées
de mobilisation est-ce qu'on en aura 14
est-ce qu'on en aura un peu plus il
n'est pas impossible qu'on en est un
plus potentiellement mais en tout cas
pour l'instant on est dans ce dans ce
faux plat voilà parce qu'effectivement
et on y viendra un peu plus tard il y
aura la question de ce qui peut se
passer et de la stratégie des uns et les
autres après la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel je vous rappelle qu'on
sera exceptionnellement en direct ce
vendredi pour analyser la décision des
sages Christelle qu'après on le crapaud
on l'a dit moins de manifestants moins
de grévistes ça c'est un constat chiffré
de cette journée mais ça veut pas dire
que l'opposition à la réforme elle est
faibli en France non pas toujours les
enquêtes on voit toujours la même chose
les mêmes chiffres à savoir
qui reste très très forte à la réforme
et à sa mesure phare le recul de l'âge
donc c'est là où on voit mal comment ça
pourrait un peu changer et un souhait de
poursuite de la mobilisation on avait
fait une enquête juste après la décision
du 49-3 on avait encore une majorité de
Français 60% qui souhaitait que le
mouvement se poursuivre donc on est
effectivement dans cette situation où
l'opinion reste très fortement opposée à
ce projet et n'a pas changé Laurent
fragerman alors où on parle il y a
quelques incidents il y a quelques
violences en marche du cortège parisien
le restaurant La Rotonde qui a été
ciblée parce que c'était le lieu qui
avait choisi Emmanuel Macron pour fêter
sa victoire une banque qui a été
saccagée on voit bien le sel le symbole
qui a été associé mais on veut pas le
donner trop d'importance à ça mais voilà
dans l'optique des syndicats comment les
syndicats gèrent cette ce risque ou
cette dérive possible alors il la
craignent j'imagine oui la craignent
d'abord c'est pas leur tradition ils ont
pas envie qu'il y ait des émeutes dans
Paris c'est pas du tout leur objectif et
de ce point et d'un autre côté il y a
une partie des gens mobilisés il y a une
forte critique des violences policières
c'est quelque chose qui est fédérateur
notamment chez les jeunes ça c'est
évident et aussi j'ai une partie des
gens qui manifeste régulièrement et qui
ont pu avoir à faire à des
activités policières qui posent problème
alors du coup quand on voit par exemple
Jean-Luc Mélenchon dans la manifestation
qui insistait sur cet aspect il faut
bien se rendre compte que c'est un
aspect clivant parce que vous avez cette
partie là des mobilisé et toute une
autre très importante qui se sent plutôt
protégées par la police et qui voit
aussi que quand on envoie des pierres
sur des policiers on n'est pas tout à
fait bienveillant donc voilà donc du
coup c'est quelque chose qui est plutôt
problématique clairement pour les
syndicats parce que ça peut dissuader
les gens de manifester mais pour
l'instant Christophe appelé on voit pas
l'opinion basculer sur cette question de
la violence parce que c'est vrai que ça
peut être on parle de stratégie de
pourrissement ça peut être une stratégie
évidente mais pour l'instant on voit pas
ça
quand les mouvements enfin ont commencé
enfin il y avait les ça a dégénéré d'un
certain point de vue ça inquiète euh les
les Français mais ça ne les retourne pas
complètement et surtout pas ça va pas
faire que tout d'un coup ils vont
devenir favorable à la réforme il y en
avait même 20% ce qui était pas
négligeable qu'il est comprenait donc
finalement qui imputait un peu la
responsabilité au gouvernement en disant
bah c'est le pourrissement qui provoque
ces débordements et on a une forme de a
ça veut dire qu'il logistifiait mais une
forme de compréhension mais généralement
même si ça crée de l'inquiétude ça ne
retourne pas du tout l'opinion il y a un
autre élément je reviens vers vous tout
de suite mais il y a un autre élément
Laurent fraggerman qui est intéressant
c'est le la fiche de paye c'est à dire
que il y a pas mal de grévistes qui ont
reçu la le le salaire du mois de mars et
ils ont vu ce que ça coûtait de faire
grève quoi c'est c'est aussi trivial et
basique que ça mais c'est un élément
très important absolument et c'est pour
ça que justement pour revenir sur 2010
moi je me suis concentré sur les
enseignants puisque papel Ndiaye a fait
une vidéo très rediffusée où il se
vantait de dire les enseignants étaient
pas à la pointe du mouvement alors j'ai
regardé les chiffres officiels je me
contente de ça il y a déjà aujourd'hui
par rapport votre chiffre annoncé en un
trimestre il y a déjà 20% de plus de
jours de grève que toute l'année 2010
c'est pour vous donner un peu une
ampleur de désenseignants plus mobilisés
cette année qu'en 2010
et surtout en plus donc effectivement ça
finit par être un chiffre important mais
le problème en fait c'est que vous avez
plus le mouvement se diminue là il est
un peu stable je suis d'accord sur une
idée du faux plat c'est à dire que dans
la fonction publique toute fonction
publique confondues c'est le même
chiffre que la semaine dernière c'est
les chiffres de Bastien Scordia du coup
on a ce qui le problème c'est que ce
sont les grévistes habituels qui vont
faire quand vous avez 6 ou 10% de
grévistes c'est un peu les mêmes et même
s'il y a des caisses de grève vous avez
une espèce d'avant-garde un peu grosse
qui va continuellement on en a vu un
exemple dans le reportage mais le reste
ne suis pas forcément alors Franck
morale je voulais qu'on s'appuie sur
votre expérience de conseiller social de
d'Édouard Philippe et du Premier
ministre parce que vous en avez vécu des
des négociations des fils notamment sur
la version la réforme des retraites
première version ce qui s'est passé hier
l'Inter syndical qui claque la porte
c'était écrit tout le monde se demandait
est-ce que ça va durer 5 minutes ou une
heure bref on dit que dans quoi une
sorte de théâtre social ainsi s'accélère
à quoi alors pardon de poser une
question basique si c'est écrit d'avance
quoi donc de toute façon il y a toujours
des rituels il y a toujours un certain
nombre de réunions avec des codes et
avec une forme de théâtralité
effectivement dans l'organisation du
dialogue social que ça soit
l'organisation du dialogue social au
niveau local ou au niveau national et
donc ce type de réunion est toujours
marqué par un certain par la prise en
considération et l'envoi d'un certain
nombre de signaux qu'elle était la
stratégie des deux parties dans le cas
d'espèces la stratégie du gouvernement
consistait à montrer que elle le
gouvernement avait la capacité de
renouer le lien avec les organisations
syndicales et de faire en sorte que les
organisations syndicales se déplacent à
Matignon donc le simple fait qu'il soit
autour de la table c'était déjà
qui me permettait une station
d'Elisabeth c'était ça c'était j'ai
réussi à faire en sorte que les
organisations syndicales se déplacent à
Matignon et évidemment on a bien vu à
travers par exemple la question de
l'ordre du jour il y avait un ordre du
jour qui n'était pas les retraites mais
Élisabeth borne avait pris soin de dire
si vous avez envie de parler des
retraites évidemment il n'est absolument
pas interdite pas lire des traites donc
on avait voilà la stratégie des
organisations syndicales c'était
vis-à-vis de leur base de montrer que
bien qu'allant à Matignon et bien ils
allaient porter un message qui était le
message du retrait de la réforme et donc
et donc ils ont tous conclu leur
intervention par allez-vous voilà de ce
point de vue là on peut dire
paradoxalement que je dis paradoxalement
parce que on a parlé dans la presse
notamment d'échec de la Réunion etc mais
paradoxalement
cette réunion au regard des objectifs
des parties que je viens d'indiquer
n'est pas un échec ni pour les années
pour les ni pour les uns ni pour les
autres c'est une étape c'est une étape
dans le processus il y aura sans doute
d'autres réunions alors la question en
réalité qui se pose par rapport à la
dynamique du mouvement social c'est le
fait qu'il y a un certain nombre de
moments clés dans un mouvement alors il
y a eu un moment clé à travers le 49-3
pourquoi ce cette histoire du 49-3 a été
un moment clé parce que le gouvernement
a sans doute fait l'erreur de dramatiser
le recours le non recours dans un
premier temps au 49-3 et donc cette
dramatisation du nom recours et
retourner contre lui puisque ça aurait
pu être un événement si ils avaient dit
depuis des jours et des jours depuis le
début il y a cet outil on utilisera si
besoin bon là la prochaine étape ça va
être le Conseil constitut il viendra
plus tard donc je vous interrompre tout
de suite sur le concentré il y aura
beaucoup de choses à dire Mathilde
sur le timing le calendrier de cette
rencontre c'était à la veille d'une
nouvelle mobilisation on a vu
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il pas mieux fallu
attendre justement cette cette date du
14 avril où l'on va connaître les
décisions du Conseil constitutionnel
pour vraiment remettre tout le monde
autour de la table est-ce que c'était
pas curieux de convoquer cette rencontre
cette semaine c'est pas incompatible le
président de la République a annoncé je
crois qui l'entendait rencontrer les
organisations syndicales après le 14
avril encore une fois le but les buts de
guerre de cette réunion était assez
réduit modeste et spécifiques et on peut
considérer qu'ils ont été atteints donc
deux de cette perspective là
effectivement le moment était plutôt le
bon il aurait été compliqué pour le
gouvernement d'organiser ce type de
réunion par exemple pendant le débat
parlementaire parce que précisément
pendant le débat parlementaire on était
au moment où c'était la démocratie
parlementaire elle est toujours
l'éternel débat démocratie parlementaire
versus démocratie sociale
votre avis peut-être la réponse à la
même question que posait Mathilde sur le
timing s'il y avait un bon timing ou un
meilleur timing pour cette pour cette
réunion c'est un bon timing si on fait
une première réunion et qu'on commence à
avoir des portes qui s'ouvrent aucune
porte n'a été ouverte c'est ça le
problème je pense que la pédagogie on a
beaucoup parlé de pédagogie en général
dans les mouvements là elle était
réussie par les syndicats et que
l'histoire de la médiation de la pose
qui avait été lancé par Laurent Berger
la semaine dernière enfin un peu plus
avant ça a marqué les esprits donc il
fallait absolument que le gouvernement
réagisse montre à son tour qui pouvait
proposer quelque chose et d'un autre
côté les syndicats finalement qui
auraient pu être divisé en refusant le
retrait ils ont pu de fait avoir une
position unie et puis Christelle il y a
la question Elisabeth borne aussi c'est
compliqué pour une première ministre qui
est fragilisée par l'échec de puisque
effectivement vous ne l'avez dit il y a
eu la volonté de d'éviter le 49-3
finalement elle a dû recourir voilà
c'est à cet outil constitutionnel
moi j'essaye de me mettre à sa place
quoi c'est dans une réunion comme ça
dans le regard des autres ils se disent
quoi les démonétiser elle a elle
fragilisé comment comment ça peut se
passer c'est très compliqué
effectivement pour elle d'ailleurs on
voit dans les enquêtes d'opinion que ça
cote de popularité a nettement baissé
après elle a beaucoup moins baissé que
celle d'Emmanuel Macron et dans l'esprit
des Français le principal responsable de
la situation ce n'est pas Elisabeth
borne c'est Emmanuel Macron donc elle
j'ai envie de dire bah elle continue sa
feuille de route on lui a dit qu'il
fallait qu'elle rétablisse le dialogue
bon elle organise cette réunion moi je
pense que ça envoie quand même un signal
que le dialogue n'est pas totalement
rompu dans nos enquêtes on voyait que
les Français étaient très partagés il y
en avait 51% qui disait qu'il pouvait
encore se parler le gouvernement et les
syndicats donc le fait est qu'ils
peuvent entre guillemets se parler parce
qu'ils peuvent se réunir autour d'une
table après sur le fond ça n'a rien
changé mais voilà ça ça occupe l'espace
en attendant cette voilà cette réunion
du enfin cette décision du Conseil
constitutionnelle alors justement c'est
la prochaine étape vendredi prochain et
je vous rappelle qu'on sera rendez vous
spécial de de sciences publiques les
groupes de gauche au Sénat ils ont
déposé ce matin leur recours au Conseil
constitutionnel tu es en écoute Patrick
Kanner qui est le président du groupe
socialiste au Sénat était au micro de
Samia de chir la matière sarez nous
avons évoqué des arguments de droit de
droit constitutionnels et nous avons dit
au conseil si ce texte passait tel qu'il
était aujourd'hui ce serait vraiment une
remise en cause des grands équilibres
insolutionnels dans la 5e République et
pour aller plus loin je propose à terme
traduit de nous rejoindre sur ce plateau
bonsoir tan bienvenue pour nous éclairer
sur ce que l'on attend de cette décision
du Conseil constitutionnel vendredi
prochain qu'est-ce qui peut se passer
alors sans sur total sans sur partielle
voilà ou résidus le suspense alors il y
a une certitude pour de nombreux
constitutionnalistes c'est que certains
points du texte n'ont rien à faire dans
ce texte un plfssr un projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
rectificative car il n'impacte pas les
finances de 2023 ce sont ce qu'on
appelle des cavaliers sociaux on a
beaucoup parlé l'index seniors le CDI
Sonia peut-être certains points qui
concernent et bien le compte pénibilité
serait dans le viseur et pourrait donc
être censurée et cela est prêt pour
effet de durcir le texte de retirer le
sucre à la potion des retraites qui n'en
seraient que plus amères en revanche
bien là-dessus on serait pas dans la
nouveauté on serait dans la droite
lignée de ce que font les sages tous les
ans tous les ans il y a des points du
budget de la Sécurité sociale qui sont
censurés parce que les parlementaires
font des petites sorties de route qui ne
correspondent pas toujours au véhicule
législatif alors on va prendre une autre
hypothèse la censure totale évidemment
ce serait une autre histoire et oui et
les saisines de la gauche et du RN
réclame et bien cette censure totale
pour deux motifs déjà on va se pencher
sur la première raison le détournement
de procédure on n'utilise pas un budget
de la Sécurité sociale pour une réforme
d'ampleur comme celle des retraites
normalement ce texte rectificatif doit
comme son nom l'indique rectifier le
budget précédent celui de 2022 et ce
n'est pas ce qu'il fait là alors est-ce
que pour autant le Conseil
constitutionnel va sanctionner le
gouvernement ça serait une surprise en
tout cas car le conseil constitutionnel
n'est normalement pas le juge du
comportement du gouvernement ce n'est
pas le rôle qu'il s'est donné jusqu'ici
donc soit il ne s'en sort pas il reste
donc dans son rôle classique mais il y a
donc là encore un effet ça crée un
précédent le gouvernement peut se sentir
alors autorisé à recommencer auquel cas
il pourrait à nouveau détourner un texte
budgétaire à utiliser le 49-3 soit ils
sont sûrs ils sont sur totalement et là
c'est une révolution pour le Conseil
constitutionnel deux raisons pour une
éventuelle censure totale quelle est la
deuxième et la deuxième raison c'est le
principe de clarté et de sincérité des
débats qui n'auraient pas été respectés
et pour le constitutionnaliste Dominique
Rousseau c'est un motif crédible écoutez
on n'a pas voté à l'Assemblée nationale
on s'est arrêté à l'article 2 on a
utilisé l'article 38 du Règlement au
Sénat qui limite à un orateur pour un
orateur compte on a utilisé l'article 44
sur le vote bloqué donc si vous voulez
la clarté la sincérité du débat n'ont
pas été respecté de manière manifeste
grave et répétez au point que le Conseil
pourrait dire que la loi n'a pas
respecté la procédure parlementaire
ordinaire et donc censurer la loi voilà
il est très affirmative de mini crosso
mais les professeurs de droits ne sont
pas nombreux sur sa ligne car
normalement et bien le Conseil
constitutionnel estime que ce n'est pas
à lui mais bien au Parlement de faire
lui-même la police de son débat
d'ailleurs et bien ce principe de clarté
et de sincérité des débats à respecter
il existe déjà depuis 2005 jamais
jusqu'ici un texte n'a été censuré par
les sages pour ce motif et depuis 1958
le Conseil constitutionnel n'a censuré
des textes que 5 fois pour des raisons
de procédure on comprend qu'il y a une
sacrée différence entre ce que le
Conseil constitutionnel peut faire et ce
qu'il va faire et oui vous avez d'un
côté le débat juridique et de l'autre le
rôle que les sages considèrent être le
leur retoquer l'intégralité d'une telle
réforme ferait changer le Conseil
constitutionnel de dimension le ferait
sortir de sa réserve de sa prudence
habituelle alors va-t-il le faire telle
est la question à laquelle je ne
répondrai pas car j'ai une chance sur
deux de me planter
mais une chose est sûre et je vous livre
alors l'analyse du politiste est
constituée une nationaliste Bastien
français soit c'est la censure totale et
on entre alors dans une crise politique
gigantesque soit et bien le texte il est
partiellement censuré du coup il est
durci la colère des Français sera
toujours là peut-être encore renforcé
bref la santé de Christ c'est pas pour
le 14 avril merci beaucoup merci pour
cette analyse alors je vais pas vous
demander aux aller aux autres de de
parier entre guillemets sur l'addition
du Conseil non c'est plus sur la la
stratégie en fait c'est ça que que je
trouve aussi intéressant c'est à dire
que vous nous disiez il y aura peut-être
plus de 14 journées de mobilisation
quand on compare avec 2010 ça se tient
là finalement la stratégie des syndicats
de l'Inter syndical ça va être quoi de
maintenir une pression mais peut-être
sous une forme un peu différente comment
vous voyez les choses mais effectivement
c'est la grande inconnue on après 14
avril Laurent Berger a indiqué je crois
et tous les mots sont importants qu'il
je cite reconnaîtrai la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel les mots sont
importants il a dit reconnaître alors ça
veut dire reconnaître la légitimité
est-ce que pour autant ça veut dire
évidemment ça serait compliqué pour lui
aujourd'hui de dire ça de dire que le
mouvement cesse après mais je pense
qu'il y aura quand même un élément
nouveau après parce que la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel si elle valide
l'essentiel du texte et notamment
l'article le fameux article sur
l'élévation de l'âge
induira assez rapidement sans doute le
gouvernement aura intérêt à le faire
assez rapidement quelques jours après le
lendemain ou sur le lendemain une preuve
médiation du texte et effectivement il y
aura ensuite une question essentielle
qui sera posée au mouvement social c'est
quelle position dans un contexte où on
est plus face à un projet qui n'est pas
arrivé au bout de son parcours
d'adoption mais on est face à une loi
alors il y aura sans doute la question
qui se posera par rapport au référendum
d'initiat partager mais c'est quand même
un parcours du combattant parce que le
référendum d'initiative partagée suppose
déjà si le principe en est validé par le
Conseil constitut de recueillir un
certain nombre de signatures et même
dans l'hypothèse 10% du corps électoral
ça fait 4 millions 800000 personnes
c'est important dans un laps de temps
assez court et puis même dans
l'hypothèse ces signatures seraient
recueillies il faut en passer ensuite
par un vote du Parlement donc de toute
façon on n'est pas rendu si vous me
permettez l'expression oui mais quand
même et je trouve cette hypothèse du
référendum d'initiative partagée on voit
bien que dans la stratégie syndicale
c'est une perspective parce que
effectivement une fois que c'est neuf
mois le le temps imparti pour réunir
c'est 4 millions 800 000 signatures bon
alors je sais pas si il faut tenir ça
peut aller plus vite d'abord mais il
faut ça veut dire qu'il faut tenir
encore plusieurs mois donc avec une
stratégie un peu différente moi je pense
qu'ils peuvent les réunir je pense que
quand on a 2 millions de personnes dans
la rue on peut avoir 5 millions 5500000
parce qu'il faut une marge parce que
certaines signatures seront invalidées
on peut les réunir après ce un effort
important mais justement ce sera un
atout pour le syndicat parce que quand
on va pour faire signer une pétition qui
est une pétition comme ça les gens
l'assiment ils se disent ça sert à rien
tandis que là ça servira à quelque chose
donc tout l'enjeu ça leur permettrait
peut-être d'utiliser de déployer
l'énergie militante oui mais pas de la
même façon c'est-à-dire pas avec une
journée d'action chaque semaine parce
que le risque d'une journée pardon
d'aller où le risque d'une journée
d'action chaque semaine c'est de finir
par avoir de moins en moins de monde
dans la rue de moins en moins de
grévistes et donc de licenciement
l'année soufflement important en fait
pour moi c'est pas du tout un problème
ils sont pas accrochés j'y reviendrai
sur cette question de la journée
d'action hebdomadaire le problème c'est
que le rythme ne serait pas surtout ce
serait juste sur l'âge de la retraite et
pas sur la durée des cotisations on va
pas non plus mettre dans la cotisation
le nombre de mois c'est pas possible
donc de toute façon ce serait que
partielle et je voudrais juste dire que
sur les grèves vous avez en gros quatre
types de il y a deux grands types de
grève et plusieurs rapports il y a la
grève hebdomadaire la grève d'une
journée qui est très classique chez les
fonctionnaires et notamment les
enseignants donc la CGT la FO et surtout
la FSU vous avez la grève dure
impétueuse de quelques jours des
secteurs d'activités où on peut bloquer
l'économie on a cette capacité là les
cheminots par exemple et
sans doute y revenir à partir de
vendredi prochain et oui ils peuvent pas
faire grève reconductibles pendant trois
mois c'est pas possible donc il y a un
problème de synchronisation
d'articulation entre les deux vous avez
aussi la majorité des entreprises du
privé ou c'est surtout la CFDT où il y a
pas de grève du tout et où donc l'enjeu
c'est même pas c'est de se mettre à
prendre des RTT ou faire une fois grève
pour aller manifester et donc le
problème d'intersyndicale c'est que
autant en 2019-2020 c'était plutôt la
grève reconductible qui était à l'avant
la scène et du coup la grève d'une
journée était en difficulté autant là
c'est l'inverse et c'est ça leur
problème c'est comment les articulent
avec un enjeu Christel craplé qui est
d'obtenir quelque chose pour les
syndicats parce que les syndicats
sortent plutôt grandi de conséquences à
nous on a mesuré leur image ils ont
gagné 7 points depuis mi-février ils
étaient très écornés comme un peu toutes
les institutions et là ils ont si je
puis m'exprimer ainsi un peu repris du
poil de la bête mais derrière ils n'ont
pas forcément obtenu quelque chose de
concret et quand même dans l'esprit des
Français ce qu'il faut obtenir c'est
l'âge c'est-à-dire que il n'y a pas de
recul de de d'agent en retraite et si
cette mesure elle est pas obtenue et
c'est quand même la plus compliquée il y
a quand même le sentiment de se dire à
quoi bon à quoi bon ça sert et un risque
finalement de d'avoir le sentiment que
bah tout ça ne vaut pas la peine et
derrière d'avoir un rejet encore plus
fort du système des hommes politiques
[Musique]
de c'est la lassitude et les aquabonises
qui sortent de cette longue séquence
d'abstention encore plus massive au
scrutin voilà c'est c'est un peu le
toujours dans les fin de conflits
sociaux dans les deuxième partie conflit
sociaux vous avez toujours ce risque de
de radicalisation d'une certaine manière
et de violence qui peuvent émerger c'est
un grand classique c'est quelque chose
qu'on rencontre assez fréquemment et
puis vous avez une autre difficulté vous
l'avez souligné à juste titre c'est la
capacité à donner de la perspective pour
après parce qu'effectivement on voit
bien que tant qu'on est dans une logique
binaire âge page c'est compliqué d'en
sortir parce que le gouvernement va
mener sa réforme jusqu'au bout et donc
sur cette question de l'âge ça sera
compliqué pour le moment social
d'obtenir des signaux et donc toute la
difficulté va être pour chacune des
parties de pouvoir scénariser un passage
vers une deuxième étape où chacun peut y
trouver son compte alors on voit bien
que le gouvernement a commencé à lancer
un certain nombre de jalons à travers
les questions de pénibilité les
questions de la loi travail alors c'est
un peu tôt c'est évidemment trop tôt
pour les organisations syndicales de
manière directe de rentrer dans ce
processus parce que ça serait admettre
dès maintenant qui passe à autre chose
que la question de l'âge mais après la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel on
passera sans doute à quelque chose de
différent quelque chose de nouveau
faudra voir faudra suivre étroitement
comment évolue l'opinion parce
qu'effectivement on sera plus face à un
projet on sera face à une loi et donc la
rejet total du Conseil constitutionnel
pour vous les elle est pas nulle mais
elle est assez faible quand même parce
que ça a été dit tout à l'heure le
Conseil constitutionnel il fait du droit
et il fait un petit peu de politique
aussi et il mesure les conséquences de
ce qu'il est amené à faire les
conséquences pour une réforme mais les
conséquences aussi pour son rôle à lui
et donc ça a été dit tout à l'heure je
pense que le le scénario le plus
probable et celui d'une censure
partielle bien évidemment on il y a une
autre question qui a été posée par
Laurent Berger le leader de la CFDT
je crois que c'était à sa sortie de de
Matignon sommes-nous en crise
démocratique et expression reprise par
la nouvelle secrétaire général de la CGT
c'était dans la manifestation parisienne
tout à l'heure on écoute ce Ie Binet
de jouer sur
la fatigue la résignation et derrière de
faire monter le rassemblement national
et c'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui et
c'est très grave en fait pour la
situation démocratique du pays et c'est
pour ça que oui on le dit on le redit on
le Martel il y a une grave crise
démocratique dont le président de la
République est responsable à cause de sa
politique et je rappelle qu'il a quand
même été élu pour lutter contre le Front
national il a été élu pour faire barrage
au Front National et voilà le résultat
de ce vote donc il ne respecte pas du
tout le monde a populaire il fait
l'inverse de ce pourquoi il a été élu
alors sur cette expression de crise
démocratique Mathilde Emmanuel Macron a
répondu depuis la Chine et pourtant il
s'était fixé comme règle comme c'est
prédécesseurs d'ailleurs de ne pas
parler de la situation politique
française quand il est à l'étranger
effectivement une règle plus plutôt
théorique puisque il n'a jamais vraiment
respecté on se souvient d'ailleurs de la
petite phrase sur les Gaulois
réfractaires c'était depuis le Danemark
Thomas voilà c'est plus fort que lui
Emmanuel Macron au premier jour de la
manifestation contre la réforme des
retraites le 19 janvier il avait pris
déjà la parole c'était depuis Barcelone
il avait défendu son texte au titre
qu'il était je cite démocratiquement
présenté et validé donc il a récidivé
hier c'était depuis Pékin à 8000 km de
Paris à peine arrivé sur le sol chinois
et quelques heures après la rencontre
entre les syndicats et Elisabeth borne
qui a tourné court Emmanuel Macron a cru
bon de s'en prendre une nouvelle fois à
Laurent Berger lors d'une rencontre sans
caméra ni micro avec des journalistes
qui a été relatés notamment par le
journal Le Monde le chef de l'État a
minimisé l'ampleur des grèves je cite
qu'on aille pas à m'expliquer que le
pays est à l'arrêt ce n'est pas vrai il
s'en est pris au leader de la de la CFDT
qui a parlé donc de crise démocratique
on l'a vu il a accusé finalement de en
galvaudan les mots de faire monter les
extrêmes et cette petite phrase que je
vous laisse apprécier Thomas si les gens
voulaient la retraite à 60 ans ce
n'était pas moi qu'il fallait dire comme
président de la République sauf qu'il y
a un argument qu'on lui rétorque depuis
plusieurs semaines tous ceux qui ont
glissé un bulletin Emmanuel Macron dans
l'urne n'était pas forcément favorable à
la retraite à 65 ans oui vu c'est les
conditions de son élection le fait qu'un
certain nombre d'électeurs ont voulu
plutôt faire barrage à Marine Le Pen au
second tour plutôt que forcément
apporter leur soutien Emmanuel Macron et
d'en donner la majorité relative ensuite
qui est sortie des urnes cet
argumentaire est pour le moins imprudent
ces déclarations depuis la Chine
d'Emmanuel Macron donne le sentiment
quelque part d'un président
quelque peu aux abois quelle utilité de
venir ajouter son grain de sel de
poursuivre le manomètre à mano avec
Laurent Berger le jour même où Elisabeth
borne tente de renouer le dialogue quel
intérêt pour ce président adepte de la
parole rare de faire le commentateur de
la crise politique dans laquelle il se
trouve cette posture est d'autant plus
étonnante que le président avait
délibérément choisi jusqu'au 49-3 de
rester en retrait sur cette réforme des
retraites alors certes il s'est dit à la
télévision prêt à endosser
l'impopularité mais ce genre de propos
alors que le gouvernement dit maintenant
vouloir apaiser n'est pas vraiment de
nature à calmer les esprits quand
Emmanuel Macron joue les maths à mort il
ne fait que renforcer l'hostilité voir
le rejet dont il fait l'objet alors on y
reviendra effectivement sur ce timing là
aussi on parlait de temporalité une
déclaration comme celle-là est-ce que
ils savent un peu le travail des avais
demande on y reviendra mais je voudrais
d'abord vous entendre Christelle sur on
peut parler d'entêtement on peut parler
d'obstination alors ça dépend
quelle qu'en politique on est ou de
courage politique sur l'attitude
d'Emmanuel Macron il paraît sur quoi
peut-être sur la faiblesse de ces
opposants politiques la division parce
que certes il n'a pas de majorité mais
il n'y a pas de majorité pour le
renverser pour l'instant je pense qu'il
le fait le pari de se dire bah avant moi
il y a déjà eu des réformes un populaire
ça c'était difficile et puis finalement
après on est passé à autre chose il fait
aussi peut-être à Paris de parler quand
même à sa base qui certes c'était fritée
il y a une partie de ces électeurs qui
s'interroge un peu mais les trois quarts
continuent quand même de le suivre
approuvent pas forcément la méthode mais
mais le fond et se dit bah comme le pays
est fracturé finalement si j'arrive à
conserver à peu près mon socle ben ça
suffira peut-être c'est un pari risqué
mais j'imagine que c'est celui qui fait
pour le moment est-ce que vous reprenez
à votre compte l'expression crise
démocratique ah oui mais moi depuis le
début je pense que c'est très important
et je pense que ça sert à rien de nier
de toute façon cette crise est
préexistante à la situation et
l'attitude du pouvoir la renforcer mais
pourquoi crise démocratique il a il a
été élu Emmanuel Macron ça veut dire que
Marine Le Pen et n'est pas une candidate
comme les autres et que donc on a
quelque soit le candidat qui
l'emporterait face à elle mais on
n'aurait pas de légitimité vous voyez ce
que je veux dire pour l'instant je suis
assez d'accord avec Sophie Binet que
plus le temps passe plus plus c'est
remis en cause non je pense que sur le
fond et ça c'est pas de la faute
d'Emmanuel Macron avec le covid avec la
guerre en Ukraine on n'a pas eu un vrai
débat
normalement les présidentielles sont le
moment politique où les Français
s'intéressent vraiment à ces questions
et font un certain nombre de choix là ça
a pas été le cas et on en paye les
conséquences aujourd'hui par ailleurs
oui une crise démocratique parce que
quand les députés ça a été dit n'ont pas
voté sur les aspects essentiels du
projet et que le temps imparti a été
limité ça c'est pas la responsabilité
d'Emmanuel Macron c'est la
responsabilité de la nuque c'était la
stratégie de la nuque ah non c'était
d'abord c'est la stratégie des défis de
confondez pas tous les parties la nuit
n'est pas suivi
non pas du tout sur les milliers au
final c'est c'est la stratégie de la
nuque qu'il a emporté quand même si
qu'il a emporté même si c'était
effectivement les autres mais il aurait
pu avoir une semaine de débat de plus ça
aurait pas été un drame on n'est pas à
la situation aux États-Unis où vous avez
des mois quelquefois de blocage
j'exagère peut-être sur des mois je
pense juste un mot peut-être
je pense que ce qui est assez frappant
c'est qu'elle tient vous l'avez dit tout
à l'heure c'est très important dans la
séquence et ça va peser pour la suite
d'ailleurs alors une forme d'union libre
ils sont pas mariés et ça peut très bien
mais je pense j'ai l'impression vraiment
quand je les vois agir que ils vont tout
faire pour éviter au moment où ils sont
peut-être en désaccord trop fort pour
éviter que ça soit un clash comme ça a
été le cas en 2003 et 2 ce point de vue
là la force des manifestations en recul
genre évidemment mais ça reste
suffisamment fort pour empêcher qui que
ce soit dans les directs dans les
directions syndicales de partir comme ça
vous avez dû vivre aussi de l'Intérieur
à une phrase du président de la
République qui s'appelait efforts du
Premier ministre non oui c'est toujours
c'est toujours des moments un petit peu
compliqué effectivement dans ce cadre là
non moi je trouve à l'inverse que
l'expression crise démocratique je la
trouve quand même
logique dans la bouche de Laurent Berger
et dans ma bouche de Sophie minet mais
je ne souscrirai pas pourquoi parce que
on se plaint assez souvent du fait et ça
a été le cas souvent dans le passé que
un certain nombre de candidats élus
n'ont respecter leur programme électoral
et il y avait quand même pas 36000
choses dans le programme électoral
d'Emmanuel Macron il y avait ça il y
avait ça et on avait même théorisé
longtemps le fait que pour les sujets
difficiles pour pouvoir les faire passer
il était essentiel de les présenter dans
les électeurs et de s'engager au moment
des élections devant les électeurs en
indiquant qu'on le ferait donc je pense
que c'est normal quand même de le
rappeler de le rappeler oui parce que
pardon nous interrompre en disant je
suis favorable à un report de la Jaga 65
ans c'était alors il y avait un petit
flou pendant sa campagne présidentielle
mais bon il savait que ce serait pas
populaire il prenait d'une certaine
façon un risque un petit risque
politique calculer mais prenez un risque
ici ça fait précisément parce que il
anticipait le fait que ça serait
compliqué et donc je pense que c'est un
point important il a été en tête au
premier tour c'est on parle du deuxième
tour mais au premier tour il était en
tête et donc c'est pour ça que moi je ne
parlerai pas de de crise démocratique il
y a une majorité relative certes mais il
y a une majorité quand même qui ainsi a
été élu avec ce point là qui était dans
le programme après c'est un moment
compliqué ça évidemment c'est un moment
compliqué et je pense que la stratégie
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure la
stratégie du président de la République
c'est sans doute de se dire voilà il y a
eu d'autres moments compliqués sous la
Cinquième République il y a eu d'autres
mouvements sociaux difficiles et donc la
stratégie dans ces cas-là c'est de
savoir gérer intelligemment le temps
c'est-à-dire envoyer à des moments clés
des signaux
envoyer des signaux d'ouverture à
certains moments des signaux de fermeté
à d'autres moments et donc effectivement
faire preuve à la fois de de hardiesse
et de diplomatie
user de la hardi à sa certain moment de
la diplomatie à d'autres c'est
extrêmement compliqué alors il y a un
mot qu'on emploie souvent c'est le mot
impasse depuis quelques jours parce
qu'il y a une sorte de double blocage il
y a un blocage social avec les syndicats
qui a un blocage politique on l'a vu
puisqu'il a fallu en passer par le 49-3
Christelle cramez ce qui est intéressant
sur ce blocage politique pour en sortir
on pourrait rêver d'une sorte de
coalition à l'allemande d'ailleurs c'est
peut-être un peu la feuille de route qui
a été qui a été donnée à Isabelle sauf
pour pour créer une coalition faut des
faut des partis politiques qui sont
prêts à y rentrer on en est très très
loin aujourd'hui
dans la culture française
lui mais encore une fois cette majorité
n'est pas d'accord sur tout et on est
quand même en assise quand même à une
forme de tripartition de la vie
politique qui est un fait nouveau et
certes il est très très loin d'être
majoritaire beaucoup de gens s'opposent
à lui mais entre la Nupe entre le RN
voilà c'est c'est cette tripartition
pour moi et le principal blocage et
c'est vrai que voilà c'est pas évident
de voir qu'elle va être la suite et la
sortie de l'impact on continue d'essayer
de cogiter pour trouver des sénarios des
scénaris de sortie de crise imaginons
alors c'est totalement improbable
aujourd'hui qu'emel Macron renonce à
cette réforme
alors on sera German est-ce qu'il
pourrait faire confiance aux partenaires
sociaux c'est-à-dire c'est une sorte de
Grenelle du temps de travail du sens du
travail dans notre dans notre société
dans notre économie alors l'avantage
pour lui ce serait qu'il pourrait
diviser les syndicats parce que dans de
la réalité je pense qu'il pourrait
travailler avec la CFDT la CFTC etc il
pourrait il aurait des points d'accord
ceci ont des propositions ce serait plus
simple pour lui et déjà en fait ce qui
est amusant c'est que en parallèle de se
blocage total au niveau de l'État le
dialogue social en tout cas vous avez
des accords interprofessionnels qui sont
signés par la CFDT avec le patronat ou
même moment donc c'est pas impossible du
tout simplement moi je trouve que ce qui
lance pour l'instant comme signaux sur
sur d'autres chantiers c'est pas
suffisant c'est à dire que c'est sur la
question des retraites qu'il faut avoir
des avancées et le paradoxe c'est que
tout est polarisé vraiment tout le monde
pense à l'âge de la retraite qui est la
mesure symbolique et donc la plus
difficile à bouger alors qu'on pourrait
négocier sur les cotisations il y a
plein de mesures techniques qui peuvent
être prises les syndicats disent on
bouge pas on veut même pas discuter si
on reste sur les 64 ans il y a quand
même deux semaines ils avaient dit un
peu autre chose je pense que si vraiment
enfin en tout cas ils après c'est à eux
de voir je vais pas décider à leur place
mais ils auraient intérêt quand même je
suis d'accord à réfléchir à une sortie
de crise eux aussi parce que sinon si on
amène
tout le monde dans la rue pour un échec
total même si leur image sera quand même
renforcée ce sera quand même difficile
alors c'est facile depuis mon siège mais
si si Elisabeth borne arrive à une
prochaine réunion et si on discutait
autour de 63 ans et demi ou 63 ans mais
à condition qu'on remette tout à plat et
qu'on lance dans la tête que fait
Mathilde colosse à un gros nail du temps
de travail on n'est pas dans ce même
atome certainement et on n'a pas pu être
de toute façon dans ce momentum puisque
dès l'origine la question de l'âge et
même la question de la durée parce que
un temps avait été évoqué le fait de
dire bon l'âge c'est compliqué mais il y
a eu d'autres réformes des retraites
dans le passé et la question de la durée
de cotisation pouvait être un paramètre
le congrès de la CFDT a fermé cette
porte c'est vrai et donc effectivement
il y avait pas de possibilités c'était
la ligne Laurent Berger mais il a pas eu
la majorité absolument quand vous
regardez ce qui s'est passé dans
l'histoire de des réformes sociales dans
notre pays pour qu'il puisse y avoir un
accord entre le gouvernement et les
partenaires sociaux il faut qu'il y ait
quelque chose à donner de part et
d'autre et là on voit bien que il y
avait pas ça il y avait pas sur la table
on n'avait pas des skis de compromis
possibles on a vu par exemple en 2013
quand il y a eu l'accord sur les plans
sociaux d'un côté avec l'assouplissement
des pittles sociaux d'un côté et la
généralisation de la complémentaire
santé de l'autre on voit bien par
exemple que là il y avait un deal avec
deux sujets qui étaient de nature
différentes là on aurait même pu
imaginer un deal avec d'autres sujets
avec le sujet des retraites mais là
aussi on n'avait rien sur la table il y
avait pas de sujet sur la table
permettant de dire ok l'âge ou la durée
ou les deux ça va être compliqué mais en
contrepartie il y a telle autre sujet
c'était pas le cas donc après pour
l'après il va falloir laisser
du soufflé et retomber effectivement les
esprits le passage de la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel mais toute la
difficulté ça sera de trouver des sujets
et vous avez fort justement mentionné le
fait que les partenaires sociaux
eux-mêmes tout seuls ont été capables
par exemple sur le partage de la valeur
de trouver ce deal mais donc la
difficulté ça sera d'avoir des sujets
qui permettent de nourrir ses équilibres
des discussions des négociations en
cours c'est ce que rappelait Geoffroy
route Bézieux à la sortie de son
entrevue avec la première ministre à
Matignon hier forcément nous on venait
pas demander le retrait donc je vous
surprends pas en vous disant que
forcément on est moins déçu la question
au fond c'est comment on reprend alors
c'est pendant trop tôt on attend le tous
le verdict du Conseil constitutionnel
enfin à un moment ou un autre chiffre
d'A bien reprendre le dialogue social je
signale d'ailleurs au passage que le
dialogue n'a jamais cessé entre les
organisations patronales et les
organisations syndicales on continue à
discuter il y a trois négociations
concours donc de ce point de vue là le
dioxal continue ça discute de quoi
d'ailleurs enfin German ça discute de
plein de sujets dont je serais bien
incapable de vous parler
radars médiatiques c'est intéressant
alors que le dialogue social il continue
il est il est en cours donc c'est quoi
le sens de la de la sortie de Geoffroy
de Bézieux c'est fait en sorte qu'on
puisse se mettre autour de la table avec
avec les syndicats sur les grands sujets
oui alors je le trouve un peu c'est un
peu facile de sa part parce qu'il a
quand même demandé fortement cette
réforme en janvier après il a disparu
des écrans et puis là il nous dit c'est
vrai qu'il a pas beaucoup
du gouvernement d'ailleurs peut-être
mais en tout cas voilà je pense vraiment
qu'il y a une question de posture
politique c'est-à-dire que cette réforme
aussi si les syndicats ont une
difficulté c'est que la marche est
extrêmement haute parce que dès le début
ça a été présenté pensé par Monsieur
Macron comme un marqueur qui allait lui
permettre d'avancer sur d'autres sujets
donc il a mis beaucoup de charges
symboliques et politiques dans cette
réforme des retraites et par conséquent
c'est cet aspect politique aussi qui
coince avec aussi cette volonté
présidentielle il l'a annoncé dans son
interview au trésor de TF1 et France 2
alors j'allais dire passer outre j'avais
employer un anglicite by-passer c'est à
dire que ce passé du du Parlement ou en
tout cas faire en sorte qu'il
intervienne moins est-ce qu'on peut
continuer de réformer ce pays avec juste
une urgence climatique il y a une
adaptation à la nouvelle donne
économique et qu'il faut faire sans le
Parlement
il faudrait avoir des textes consensuels
et là on est tellement dans un climat
d'hostilité de division que je vois pas
très bien les textes qui pourraient
susciter un consensus ou alors des
textes mineurs enfin qui doivent exister
mais moi les quatre années à venir là du
du second quintéen me paraissent
complexe il va falloir sortir de cette
situation mais voilà j'ai pas la
solution
je pense que exécutif l'aurait trouvé
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce premier débat je vous dis
évidemment à bientôt sur public Sen